- Das ist Yara.
- Ja, sie ist hübsch.
- Sie lebt in Deutschland.
- Wohnt sie hier in der Stadt?
- Aber wo ist das?
Kennt ihr Yaras Fahrradladen?
- Eh eh.
- So. Was möchtet ihr trinken?
- Was gibt es denn?
- Wir haben … Apfelsaft, Wasser, Bier,
Wein, Cola und Limonade.
- Also, ich nehm ein Bier.
- Wir haben auch Kaffee
und Tee im Angebot …
- Bier, danke.
- Für mich bitte einen Kaffee.
- Mit Milch und Zucker?
- Ja, mit viel Milch, aber wenig Zucker.
Ah warte, ich mache das.
- Was ist mit dir, Nico? Hast du auch
Durst? Was möchtest du trinken?
- Cola, bitte.
- Alles klar. Dann nehme ich Limonade.
- Also, Freunde, ich habe ‘ne Idee!
Wir …
wir posten das Foto von Yara bei Book
und fragen: Wer kennt diesen Fahrradladen?
Und so finden wir die Adresse raus.
- Ja, vielleicht.
- Habt ihr Hunger?
- Hunger? Hungry?
- Ja!
- Hier sind die Speisekarten!
- So, also dann prost!
- Prost!
- Wo ist denn Nawin? Ist er nicht hier?